to change our planet.
César,
make you the man you are.
They have the moon that gravitates
and the fish that fall off.
They give their life.
They have all the goods of the good.
A space
and a path
to the dreams of humans.
Lift it, follow your filets
and already other chimneys.
Come from, existed.
If you know, it's the age of the Earth.
Oh, the Earth has to be at least as old as we are.
But no point listening to him.
The Earth is thousands of years old, even hundreds of thousands.
I'd say hundreds of millions.
Uh-huh.
Hundreds of years old.
That's correct.
That's a billion anyway.
How many is that?
A thousand million. Everybody knows that.
That's right, but it's really hard to get such high numbers in my head.
Well, today we try to make things easy to understand.
Galileo demonstrated that the Earth goes around the sun,
and Newton devised laws of gravitation.
But when did the whole thing start?
An archbishop of Ireland, James Usher,
studied all the texts in existence,
some taken from the oldest manuscript.
He studied and searched for years and years,
and then one day...
You rang for me, Your Grace?
Yes, I found it.
Oh, what was it you lost?
I didn't lose anything,
but all my life I've sought the date the Earth was created.
In these, I did find it.
And these.
Oh, and just when was it?
Well, it was 4,004 years B.C., the 29th of October.
You even found the exact date?
Yes, oh my, yes.
I even know the hour.
It was at 9 o'clock in the morning.
That's really good.
In 1681, an English scientist, Thomas Burnett, announced that when the Earth was formed,
it was perfectly flat until God became angry with men and launched the deluge.
In 1696, another Englishman, William Whiston, said that God, in his anger, was sending a comet toward the Earth.
In 1735, a Frenchman, the Abbey Plouche, said God would rattle the Earth.
No one, not even the scientists, could yet comprehend that the sacred book, the Bible, spoke in symbols and that religion and science need not be antagonistic.
Georges Buffon was surely one of the first to demonstrate it.
Benton, if I toss this stick, half the time it will land on the boards without touching on the line.
All right, you're on.
I'll bet it does.
One golden louis.
Sir, you are going to lose.
Who are you, sir?
My name is George Buffon.
I did some calculations.
Given the length of your stick and the width of the floorboards, sir, you have almost no chance.
See?
Very well, throw it again.
Tell me, did you do a mathematical calculation?
Yes, an easy probability problem.
Since you brought me bad luck, so you owe me a golden win, monsieur.
My name's Maupertuis, member of the Royal Academy.
I find your calculations interesting, monsieur, uh...
Buffon, Georges-Louis de Buffon.
In fact, it's simple. A little arithmetic and geometry...
Merci. Uh-huh. I would like to present you at the Royal Academy of Sciences.
And so I suggest we admit, monsieur Buffon, to our academy.
I see in him a great talent.
What has he done to earn that honor?
Excellent work in mathematics.
And studies on wood quite useful to the Royal Navy.
Yes, I am familiar with his studies. Excellent work.
He was a member of the Royal Academy at the age of 27, then Intendant of the Royal Gardens.
Buffon was to undertake a tremendous task, write the history of the world.
Nobody since Aristotle the Greek 2,000 years earlier had attempted that.
Do you realize what a colossal task it would be?
Monsieur de Bontemps, we shall do our work at my property in Montbar.
We'll work undisturbed, it's much quieter.
Paris is a real madhouse.
What a strange animal.
Because of its long neck, it can reach leaves at the treetops.
Here is the pig's ancestor.
Now you and I are off to Paris.
We'll put on a little show so we're not forgotten.
Yes, we'll organize quite a spectacle.
We'll have to invite the king.
His Majesty the King Louis XV.
Here, Madame Pompadour, it appears she's a great favorite of the king.
Majesty, the sun is a massive fire, giving off enormous heat, as you know,
By concentrating its rays, the way Archimedes did in his time, we may set fire to far-distant objects.
Is it possible?
No, it's a legend. Even the great Descartes says that's impossible.
No, sire. He's wrong. It's beautiful.
Go and see. Sire, you can melt iron with it.
This thing is impossible. You will see, sire. Truly cheated, majesty.
This comet broke off a piece of the sun, this hot mass cooled down, and eventually became our Earth.
And did it require a long time?
thousands of years oh more than six thousand yes infinitely more your theory contradicts the bible
my friend we must not mix up science and religion and that's exactly what i have written
buffon contradicts genesis he considers man to be no more than an animal like all others
he speaks about the formation of planets but we know the lord created them he dares to claim that
one day the sun will go out but brother lignac mr buffon is very religious this work is wicked
It's an insult to God, and to ban it is our duty.
We might content ourselves by asking for clarification of certain passages.
Out of the question, he withdraws into prison.
Oh, look here, Brother Lignac, do relent.
This is ridiculous.
Write this down.
Dobonton, the Sorbonne, accuses me of contradicting the church.
I warned you.
In history, there was another.
Earth does not turn around the sun, so I recant, because God has so ordained me.
All the same, Dobonton.
The times aren't the same. Galileo lived in the last century.
Still, I'd be careful.
Yes, the best part of valor is discretion.
Here is Monsieur Buffon's reply.
I withdraw everything I said in my book concerning the formation of the earth,
and in general, anything that is seen to be in total contradiction to the story of Moses.
It's pure hypocrisy.
Rargh! Sensei!
Traveling yak, Monsieur Buffon has offered to publish a retraction in the next book he writes.
What more can we ask?
Routhon went on writing his monumental natural history.
Then he kept wondering how long the Earth had existed.
Hmm, I...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
The Earth was very hot and then it cooled down.
The time it takes these metal balls to cool down will let me calculate the time it took the Earth to cool down.
Nonsense, man! Hot objects all cool down at the same rate.
Very well. Pick this one up.
Age of the Earth has to be at least 75,000 years.
Sacrilege! The Earth was created 6,000 years ago.
The truth is, the Earth is no doubt much, much older than that, perhaps millions of years.
Such a notion is grotesque, beyond comprehension. He doesn't know what he's talking about.
This would be the first time a scientist asserted that the Earth had not been created in six days
and that its age had no relevance to the mythical one described in the Bible.
Buffon gave the evolution of the universe, their classification, and even dividing it into periods.
And so, the very first of Buffon's periods is when the solar system with the Earth are formed.
And the second period is when our planet solidified.
Great relief in landform was created then, and, uh, and the third period, the Earth cooled down.
This brought about enormous modifications in its structure.
Fourth period, volcanoes erupting and the water shifting once more and remodeling the Earth's crust.
And the fifth period, the land still forms only one continent.
Life forms appear and they evolve.
Sixth period, land masses begin to drift apart.
Seventh period, man appears.
Of course Buffon's ideas weren't very precise,
but for the time it was a completely revolutionary approach.
Why was it, after all his calculations,
Buffon went on to say that the Earth was only 75,000 years old?
At first he wanted to put the date considerably earlier than that.
3,500,000, for example.
But he was afraid they'd say he was crazy.
Of course, in the light of modern science today, we know the Earth is a thousand times older than that, four and a half billion years.
Hey, Maestro, it's impossible for me to get large numbers like that. I'm dizzy.
You say the Earth didn't have any life on it for such a long time?
Well, it changed slowly, a little bit at a time, but look here.
It might be easier for you to comprehend its evolution if we all take an imaginary trip into the past, eh?
Imaginary trip, Maestro? How can we?
Imagine that we have a time machine like this one.
If it works.
It's not bad at all for a machine we imagined.
The time lever is there.
If you pull it back, you go back in time.
And when you push it, you go forward into the future.
Is that possible?
Of course.
In imagination, everything is possible.
Who wants to go?
Me.
Me too.
Since there are only two places, you two will have to go first.
Me? I want to go, Maestro.
There, you see?
Now, you punch in the date of your destination in time, all right?
And with this control, you go.
Have you got it?
All set.
Now, we'll follow your imaginary voyage on this screen.
And don't ever forget, the minute you're in any danger, pull the alarm and you'll come right back to the present.
I mean, when do we?
You start three billion years ago, but you don't want to be there long.
It's very, very hot.
Disappeared.
You can never get me in one of those things.
Three billion years in the past. Over.
Hey, look at that!
Sticks is snucking.
Can you hear me, spaceship?
Guess you're three billion years away, right?
The Earth's already cooled down and life exists, hm?
Life in the water.
Sample over.
Is your only carbon dioxide another dangerous game?
An automatic sampling microscope.
Children, those are the first living creatures.
The first ones?
Tiny living cells with a simple structure.
My hundred million years in the past.
See any fish in the water?
You'd better go on to a later period, about, uh, minus 300 million years.
Only Maestro exactly was the Carboniferous.
The era was very hot.
The first insects came, the reptiles,
and then all that vegetation that would be transformed into coal.
That's the Carboniferous era.
Then now, children.
Something fabulous. Are you ready? Years ago.
But for this time, you'll see the Earth from high up.
We go up?
The Earth has changed.
Continents are on the move.
180 million years.
Get out now. The air is good to breathe.
But don't go too far, there are real beasts around.
Mammals, in a way, are ancestors.
Don't disturb toward the lagoon on the left.
Imaginary, the same.
Careful, or it's 66 million years ago.
They're both safe.
66 million?
Hey, be careful!
Oh, we forgot about our earphones.
Right here, I better go back and get 'em.
Okay, we forgot about our earphones.
You must leave.
Go where--
We have to go!
Do you see?
And in the evolution of our planet,
and you saw the end of the dinosaurs.
So, they ever took us, did they?
It was scientists who reconstructed the past, and so demonstrated that Buffon was right.
Yes, he's the one, he gets all the glory for all our modern biology, Buffon.
And evolution, and for putting the history of the Earth into the forefront, with its fauna and flora.
The study of the Earth's history.
The study was finally getting to replace theology.
The man's coming, he's going to leave the Earth, but not!